previously on TV since I am so happy
we're moving here you are so smart to
thought of us I wouldn't give up my
family for anything look for all the
chakras in the world
[Music]
and your horoscope says on the fifth a
special someone is going to give you a
gift
this is a horoscope or a prophecy you
are going to make a joke about my
special present
watching Monica worry about something
that hasn't happened to setting off my
anxiety doesn't she know that worry is a
misuse of imagination I read that on
Twitter just before my daily blocking
binge haters gonna hate and Taytay
taught me to shake it off and on the
19th a secret crush announces itself
once again we see Rachel unleash drama
and smugly sit back while her friends
unravel around her rachel is a villain I
can't even use Chandler's computers to
find porn and that's only cuz it's right
there when you turn it on I ask porn in
2000 when we'd asked Jeeves to show us
all the dirty things and they'd load
from top to bottom freeze and start
again 45 seconds later I think our
lover's spat will start a little early
this month which should come as no
surprise to anyone because Chandler and
Monica have now become the writers
dumping ground for marital stereotypes
it's wrong Ross there's plenty of room
on the couch for your skinny ass so cool
it with the aw shucks bo do you ever
wonder if at this very moment in time
Jennifer Aniston was thinking what am I
getting myself into here Rachel and I
have appointments to get our hair cut if
you listen closely you can hear her and
her monologue please don't make me cut
my hair in layers again I really want
this guy to like me it would really help
me out a few guys could be here to kind
of make me look good sure I can help
with that burn the pocket of fuzzy
pajama button-up also do you really want
someone who sits like this to try and
make a good impression this man spread
hand for cup and foot propped up display
is horrifying when do I get to meet the
robot Joey Tribbiani this is he's so
lifelike I mean I get that Joey's
supposed to be dumb but there's dumb and
then there's make Homer Simpson look
like he's in Mensa level don't let you
guys get acquainted with fists what a
strange hand gesture to use when
introducing two people I spent two years
developing this machine it's absolutely
state-of-the-art its horror robot is
absolutely not state-of-the-art in fact
the big news in 2000 was that robots had
evolved from four legs to two legs with
Sony's SD r3 and while yes I had to look
that up it was totally worth it to see
this clip you're welcome I thought
doesn't really look like he can do
anything
robotic all body why can't you get a
girlfriend your own age
this is robbing the cradle joke three of
an eventual 15 in this episode alone but
it's kind of deserved right we know
Elizabeth is around 20 here and the best
friends scientists working tirelessly in
a lab in Sacramento have determined Ross
is a
to be around 32 so if we use the 1/2 H +
7 rule Rho shouldn't be dating anyone
younger than 23 so yeah questionable age
gap relationships - the ever-expanding
list of Ross's character flaws thank you
going out with my daughter Ross okay I
can I can see that you know who else
could see that and probably saw it
coming Elizabeth for some reason is
acting incredibly nonchalant through the
entire exchange you would think of all
people she would have been able to give
Ross a heads up about her dad's
mannerisms also the hell is the purpose
of this episode except for a stunt
casting at a chummy favor after filming
the whole nine yards I mean Bruce Willis
is just playing Jimmy the Dullahan it
serves no purpose to the story because
Ross cared about any of his previous
girlfriends fathers is there a mrs.
Steven there's a mr. Bing so the
standard in relationship is that
Chandler gets heat for looking at poor
but Monica can momentarily throw a
marital caution to the wind and openly
flirt with a stranger I get that a lot
there's a fine line sometimes between
charm and smarm but I'm pretty sure
early century Bruce Willis falls
completely on the smarm side of that
line you can communicate a lot of things
with a smile Bruce's communicates hi I'm
an [ __ ] paul asked ross to call him
mr. Stevens was as clearly Ross's
attempt to gain some ground in the
testosterone race that's right the sin
is for testosterone [ __ ] the
little girl creeps me out you said the
baby why would the baby creep me out why
would a little girl creep you out better
question why would a toilet paper
company called very soft with a tagline
of extra soft use this image to convey
their brand there is nothing soft about
ski blades and a frozen lake also I can
solve this ridiculous fight take the TP
out of the bag when you get home please
left-hander's Paul's view of the keys is
obstructed by Rachel's sweater in the
couch itself which means Paul has x-ray
vision which honestly may explain why he
can see through Ross's bowl we yeah it
usually takes two people to to
lightsaber battles with their penises
yes I suppose you're right so why don't
you just get him fired
damn that's dark thinking there Phoebe
is this really annoying with our
character shouldn't she be suggesting a
bonding exercise like goat yoga or trust
Falls Joey Tribbiani
Joe I'm glad I found you find it was she
calling all his landline hangout spots
asking for Joey until she remembered he
has his own pink cell phone also flip
phones obsoleted mac and cheese Oh Oh I
mean friends can be good but sometimes
when it's bad it's SNL sketch that got
cut address back when we last saw Joey's
secret stuffed animal it didn't need
goggles
why does
huggsy need no God if this were real
life Rachel wouldn't walk this direction
around the table to get to Ross she
turned the other way in a direct path oh
stage cues
why do you complicate things Ross's
instinct is to blatantly lie about
seeing someone he's uncomfortable around
the failure of all relationships really
do rest squarely on his shoulders
you came in you got all awkward you ran
to the bedroom you were shouting Joey
Joey it's Jennifer mounting Bruce's
lines here scene stealer
he lost his keys so he was looking for
them in your mouth no downstairs well
that's even kinkier you gotta go back
there and kiss some serious robot ass
little-known fact
Alex Garland got the initial idea for
the ex machina screenplay from this very
episode Chantilly was a restaurant known
for its fine dining floral entryway and
cozy corner seating that's crunches for
people around the same side of the table
so they can all be in the same camera
shot it has an incredibly high score on
Yelp from the TV sitcom director
demographic so Ross was in college and
decided to jump at the chance to take a
young girl to her high school prom I
definitely did not see that one backfire
friends Ryder is 40 years later the Sun
I feel like every single one of the
writers just had the same shocking
revelation Carol and I are on excellent
terms as I'm sure you are with your life
I'm sorry II forgot Paul's wife had died
and you continue to insinuate you're a
pervert yes it is unbelievable
even Ross with all his flaws should have
a far better ability to converse with an
adult human I know their friends and
their lives are rarely spent apart from
each other but at what point does
hanging out in a married couples
apartment turns strange also is Phoebe
happy to find her friends arguing one of
the name of Ursula is up with this evil
Phoebe nonsense and you are the queen of
everything Thanks
damn audience saviours screaming
laughter for something actually funny
like well I guess I'm so burned out on
friends nothing feels funny anymore Ross
did learn something from each marriage
how to make the next one even shorter
Elizabeth's dad would be excellent at TV
since I have to pee again
I wonder what's in the purse we know
it's not a smartphone god what a
nightmare we lived in back in 2000 when
going to the bathroom and just going to
the bathroom you know what daddy if you
don't like Ross that's fine
hang on sweetie the adult males are
talking no need to make the audience
think that you're anything but a prop to
boost a weird story line with the
creepiest character in the series and
inflate the conflict with an overpriced
guest star let the menfolk work this one
out I hope they're not actually shooting
the show from this angle because the set
designers left out an entire wall so
live why are you attracted to me you
give me indication of Stephanie
reassemble the shop I'm sorry in five
years you have never apologized to me
this quickly something's going on here
I'm gonna find out what it is